is there an opportunity for the daddy of
Stargate Brad Wright to return to the
franchise
police
welcome to psycheck your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
so it was actually on Sidetrack first
and exclusively 18 months ago that we
told you that Amazon did not want Brad
right involved in the new Stargate
franchise that they were planning now at
the time I got called a liar I got
called names I got called lots of things
but it turned out to be accurate Brad
Wright was not in Amazon's plans at the
time now I have to say that I thankfully
and luckily get to speak to Brad right
occasionally and he is a lovely guy
um and he has not been approached by
Amazon
but
things have changed to Amazon a little
bit and it opens up a possibility a
possibility that has been discussed by
MGM Executives but we'll get to that in
a minute initially why was Brad Wright
not involved in Amazon's plans up till
now well basically it was nothing to do
with brand right really they have
nothing against Brad right actually
Amazon have hired bad right to do other
projects in the past but there were
actually two quite big reasons why
Amazon never really wanted Brad right
involved firstly they did want fresh
blood this is something they do a lot
with reboots a lot of Studios have done
this over the years they want fresh
ideas fresh blood they don't want to
necessarily rehash the old stuff so the
way to do that is bringing new people
don't bring in the original creators now
Babylon 5 is about to get a hard reboot
and they are actually bringing back the
original Creator Jane Michael schizinski
one of the reasons why they're doing
that is because they have actually
finally realized that we don't
necessarily like reboots when it brings
something new to a franchise that we
dearly love except for maybe Battlestar
Galactica no reboot is ever really been
that successful continuations like Star
Trek the Next Generation have been
massively popular but let's remember
that next Generation actually did bring
back Gene Roddenberry at least at first
and then Braga actually really stuck
very heavily to the ideas that Gene
Roddenberry laid down in the Star Trek
Bible that he created Now new track
ignored that and that's a different
conversation but Studios do seem to be
actually finally realizing that we do
actually prefer continuations of beloved
franchises we don't necessarily like it
when they're completely revamped new is
not always better yeah but those are
business reason as well why Brad Wright
was not really considered to be involved
in this because basically a year or 18
months ago well Amazon were actually
making these plans they were looking at
doing it the way they've been doing
other projects over the last few years
in partnership with somebody else now
this is basically because up until very
recently Amazon didn't own any Studios
of their own they now own six of Culver
Studios and that's also where Amazon
Studios um headquarters is and they're
going to be renting from another company
called the Hackman group a load more
Studios now as I say though 18 months
ago they didn't
so they assumed they'd have to do it
with a partner they were looking at
Warner Brothers perhaps Sony
um and maybe there are a couple of other
smaller Studios with them basically just
funding somebody else to make the show
for them via MGM but now we've had the
strikes now that has changed thinking at
Amazon they have obviously like I say
the six Studios already they're up and
running they're actually already making
stuff there's a big Eddie Murphy film
being made there right now
they have plans in place to quadruple
the amount of Studios they have in the
next 12 months so all of a sudden Amazon
might actually have the capacity to make
things themselves all of a sudden they
don't need to have a partnership with
another big Studio like Warner Brothers
all of a sudden
they might actually be able to go about
it themselves and in that case all of a
sudden
Brad Wright's vision for Stargate is
possible again so why are the strikes
making a difference because Amazon are
having to put everything on pause it's
allowing them to get an awful lot of
stuff ready that they weren't
necessarily going to have time to do
they have accelerated their plans to get
hold of more Studio space they have the
opportunity to take a breather from
other projects and actually plan ahead a
little bit all things that they really
didn't think 12 months ago they'd have
the opportunity to do so Stargate was
going to be announced a San Diego Comic
Con just gone a few months ago my
understanding was that there was in
principle a deal with a partner but it
was never actually agreed there was no
actual final signature it was never
actually set in stone so Amazon now
don't have to do that anymore it is my
understanding talking to sources that I
do close to MGM Amazon the Amazon are
taking this time and taking this
opportunity to actually reconsider a lot
of their plans for the next couple of
years
and that does include Stargate my
understanding is that Michael Wright who
is currently the head of MGM plus has
always been a big fan of Brad Wright's
vision and has always argued that one
Stargate should return with a series and
two that it should be led by Brad Wright
now as I say that was not an option
before
apparently according against my sources
Lindsey Sloan who is actually one of the
heads of scripted material for MGM or
scripted television for MGM is also a
big fan and apparently in the last
couple of months has been trying to
argue The Point again that why not bring
Stargate completely in-house get it run
from MGM bring Brad Wright back in we've
already got a pilot script that's
already gone through nearly 12 months of
development we've got somebody in Brad
ride that actually knows exactly what
they're doing and how to move forward
with Stargate and that we don't have to
bring in any other partners MGM already
has the capacity to do this all they
actually need is the studio space and
all of a sudden because of the strike
they might actually have it
so why complicate the situation why
bring in too many cooks that more than
likely will spoil the broth why not
actually just do what the fans want now
we've been arguing that we want Stargate
back and that we want Brad right
Sidetrack has been shouting for over 18
months that we want Brad right involved
yes we reported the news first that he
wasn't but we also reported that we
weren't bloody happy about it and we
would love Brad Wright to be involved so
to recap there are Executives at MGM
arguing this point
but also they're arguing another big
point that Amazon do not want to be
burned by the rings of power problem
again the rings of power was created by
basically a bunch of writers I haven't
really ever done anything else due to
problems with the contract really from
day one a lot of fans Tolkien fans were
not happy about the direction of the
show anyway and they weren't happy that
you know many characters were gender
swapped or race swapped or blah blah
blah something I don't personally agree
with but that's what they were unhappy
about basically a lot of Tolkien fans
and a lot of YouTube channels were
shouting that this was going to be a
load of rubbish before it ever came out
and there are people at Amazon that
believe that's seriously harmed the
franchise and cost them money they do
not want the same again when they bring
Stargate back and these Executives like
Michael Wright and Sloan who as I say
aren't really the top people at MGM
right now are arguing that the best way
to avoid the rings of power problem
bring back Pride right now we argued a
year ago just bring it back as a
consultant anything okay you've got this
business model you've got this way of
doing it with a partner fine bring him
he's a consultant
but now people like Michael Wright are
actually arguing they don't need to even
do that they could just bring him back
as the showrunner as the writer they
could follow his lead and his vision
they could allow him to put together a
team like he's done before that can
deliver a brilliant Stargate franchise a
Stargate franchise that we as Gators
would recognize as Stargate
that they could use the relationship
that Brad Wright has with many of the
actors to get them back
and the understanding of those actors
that he has that means when we then get
those actors back and those characters
back there'll be characters again that
we recognize
and this could be done very easily
because Brad Wright would be more than
happy to do it
or Amazon has to do
is ask so this is not just speculation
this might actually be a possibility
now I am very aware that Brad right has
not been approached I am very aware that
this may never happen
but I'm also very aware talking to the
people that I do that there are people
at MGM that want it to happen
so as fans and as a YouTube channel that
loves Stargate I have to talk about it
and we have to talk about it but I would
love to know what you think right now so
please get into the comments and tell me
is Brad Wright returning to Stargate a
distinct possibility for you and is it a
possibility that excites you or do you
actually think that fresh blood is a
much better idea I'd love to know what
you think get to the comments if you are
new to the Channel please like subscribe
hit that Bell notification it really
helps us out you'll never miss any of
our new videos also you can follow all
of these links they're in the
description as well and you can go to
our Twitter page and nine chevron's
website ad Discord server Etc where you
get to speak to like-minded people other
fans of Stargate you also get to SCI
dashtrack.com where you can get
brilliant merchandise like t-shirts and
jumpers and all stuff Star Trek Stargate
everyone else related finally don't
forget that you can go to our patreon
page where most of our new videos appear
first and a small contribution each
month you get to see them without the
adverts as always please stay safe and
I'll see you next time
foreign